this is probably a dead giveaway that I'm
balls deep into my 30s
but my baby broccoli are finally ready
and I couldn't be more excited
and that means broccoli is on the menu for the foreseeable
but this herby blanched broccoli salad is so crunchy and so flavoursome
it's pretty much a crime not to make it
first slice your broccoli, stalks & all
into bite size pieces
submerge them in boiling water for two minutes
then ice water for two minutes before  draining and patting dry
To this I'm adding some sliced bok choy
spring onions coriander
mint all from my garden
thank you
alongside carrots
capsicum and cashews
I wanna go light with the dressing
to really hero the flavour of the broccoli
I’m mixing soy sauce
sesame oil rice wine vinegar
peanut butter lemon juice and brown sugar
Give it a whisk and then
finish it off with a couple of tablespoons of toasted sesame seeds
for an extra earthy flavour
and then I think the trick is to massage the salad
I could be wrong
but I swear it scratches my brain and makes the veggies taste better
I've laid down a bed of seasoned sushi rice
and I'm topping that with some seared teriyaki chicken
a little bit of extra salad dressing and some homemade toasted nori sheets
this dinner was very demure, very mindful
there was a good crunch left in that broccoli
The kids even enjoyed it without complaint
for a change